nous avons eu la chance de passer la
journée dans la demeure des duc de sully
sur loire
nous avons pu en visiter les moindres
recoins et on partage nos découvertes
avec vous je vous laisse profiter de ce
reportage
les châteaux étaient équipés de chambre
du roi il fallait pour accueillir le roi
en toutes circonstances à tout le monde
donc ici vous avez la chambre du roy
pour accueillir le souverain en
déplacement la chambre du roy le passage
des grands hommes
leduc maximilien de béthune le premier
propriétaire des lieux inattendus henri
iv qui n'est jamais venue contrairement
à son petit fils louis xiv caché au
château de sully sur loire pendant la
fronde plus tard voltaire séjourna au
château vieille depuis de sept siècles
cette demeure est un lieu de souvenir et
on revisite l'histoire de france c'est
toujours très intéressant le val de
loire c'est un grand musée finalement
c'est au xviie siècle que maximilien de
béthune futur duc de sully sur loire
achète la demeure qui restera pendant
près de quatre siècles la propriété de
la famille
malheureusement il y avait ici un
grammage en 1918 en 1918 il ait eu un
terrible incendie qui a ravagé toute
cette partie
ça se passe en janvier en janvier 1918
en plein hiver en pleine nuit cette
partie la plus luxueuse a été
reconstitué à l'identique telle qu'elle
était avant l' incendie
le mobilier datent du xviiie siècle
ça nous permet aussi d'apprendre par
rapport à l'histoire des choses qui sont
passés qui ne faut pas reproduire ou
alors des trucs qui sont très bien
passées et qu'on peut encore reproduire
est ce que l'on ne veut pas reproduire
ce sont les guerres de religion vécue
par maximilien de béthune
à 12 ans il connaît à paris la saint
barthélémy alors qu'il est protestant
sept mille à trois mille d'entre eux
sont tués
donjon douves des marques de l'époque
médiévale et une histoire qui se
prolonge
c'est l'occasion de d'évoquer un peu
comme on vit autrefois bien sûr mais
c'est aussi l'occasion d'évoquer des
grands personnages qui ont vécu la com
évidemment le duc de sully des rois
comme louis xiv voltaire rue voltaire
mais aussi des personnages importants
voltaire jeanne d'arc saint lieux où
l'histoire de voeux de france et c'est
fait
cette histoire est inscrite au sein de
cette demeure aujourd'hui devenu un lieu
de mémoire
je suis maintenant en compagnie d'adrien
le guide du château de sully sur loire
bonjour adrien bonjour nous sommes ici
dans la chambre du roi là où les rois se
reposer lorsqu'il était dans les
environs
juste derrière moi on voit un immense
tableau de henri iv
pourtant il n'ya jamais séjourné est-ce
que vous pouvez vous expliquer pourquoi
en effet henri iv n'est jamais venu ici
par contre il a eu une très grande
importance pour le château tout d'abord
il est beaucoup d'importance pour
maximilien de béthune de duc de sully
il était grand ami protestants ensemble
et il a eu beaucoup de responsabilités
grâce à henri iv
ensuite c'est henri iv qui a créé le
duché de sully donc sans régate pas du
dessus dit et pas de château de sully
comme il existe encore aujourd'hui donc
on comprend que maximilien de béthune
le premier propriétaire en tant que duc
de sully sur loire était proche de henri
iv
on dit que il l'aurait influencé henri
iv à se convertir au catholicisme et lui
est resté protestants effectivement
sully était protestant henri iv aussi
était protestant d'origine mais sully a
tout de même conseillé henri iv pour
devenir catholique pour mettre un terme
finalement aux guerres de religion donc
ils étaient converties en 15 100 93
est élevé à 1 494 il a été couronné roi
sûrement grâce justement à sa conversion
un an avant donc c'était une sorte c'est
une sorte de stratégie pour de
maximilien de conseillers henri iv
d'être catholique exactement si oreca
n'avait pas été catholique
les guerres de religion aurait pu
continuer encore longtemps et c'était
dommage dommageable pour le pays le
royaume est aussi poursuivi lui même qui
était protestant wiki qui aurait pu
perdre du coup son qu'il ya pas mal de
pouvoir et sachant qu'à la mort d'henri
iv en 710 doucement sully aussi perdu
une partie de ses pouvoirs